Im Bereich der KI wird es nie
langweilig. Und da der Dev Day von
OpenAI am 29. September ansteht, also
in etwa 72 Stunden, sehen wir erste
große Leaks und Einblicke in das, was
OpenAI möglicherweise vorstellen wird.
Von neuen Modellen bis hin zu
potenziell bahnbrechenden KI-Agenten:
Zunächst sieht es so aus, als hätte
OpenAI versehentlich eine seiner
größten Dev-Day-Neuerungen namens O
geleakt. Dies ist Berichten zufolge ein
Konkurrenzprodukt zu Lösungen wie
Robot und Hermes Agent. Es könnte von
einer Variante von Astra namens AON
angetrieben werden, die speziell für
lang laufende Aufgaben entwickelt wurde
. Hinweise auf O erschienen kurzzeitig
auf dem Upgrade-Bildschirm von ChatGPT,
während interne Konfigurationen O als
Anzeigename und „negative O“ als
E-Mail-Endung erwähnten. Das deutet
darauf hin, dass es möglicherweise
E-Mails und andere Aufgaben für dich
erledigen könnte. AON mag derzeit eine
interne Implementierung der
benutzerdefinierten ChatGPT-Agenten
sein, aber OpenAI könnte dies in einen
verbraucherorientierten Assistenten
umwandeln. Aber das ist noch nicht
alles. OpenAI bereitet sich Berichten
zufolge auch darauf vor, seine
ultraschnelle API nach dem Dev Day zu
erweitern. Ein neuer
Geschwindigkeitsregler mit den Modi „
schnell“, „Standard“ und „
ultraschnell“ wurde in der
Response-API-Spielwiese entdeckt.
Kombiniert man das mit dem kürzlich
gesichteten 500-
Dollar-ChatGPT-Pro-Max-Plan, der die
schnellsten Antworten verspricht,
scheint OpenAI massiv auf
Geschwindigkeit und Infrastruktur zu
setzen. Unterdessen könnte Anthropic
kurz vor dem Dev Day noch einen
Seitenhieb gegen OpenAI verteilen, da
die Veröffentlichung von Sonnet 3.5
extrem kurz bevorsteht. Partner sollen
Zugriff auf einen neueren Checkpoint
erhalten haben, der noch besser ist als
der erste. Und wie ich bereits
erwähnte: Wenn Sonnet 3.5 mit
günstigeren Preisen auf den Markt
kommt, wie bei GPT-4o, könnte das
revolutionär sein, da die ersten Tests
bereits einige verrückte Ergebnisse
geliefert haben. Und es ist etwas, das
GPT-4o bei einer überraschend hohen
Anzahl von Aufgaben sogar übertrifft
und dabei potenziell deutlich
günstiger ist. Bei Mistral wurde
Mixtral 8x22B Flash in einem frühen
Commit im GitHub-Repository von Mistral
entdeckt, bevor die Verweise wieder
entfernt wurden. Und nach den frühen
Ausgaben zu urteilen, sieht dieses
Modell für etwas, das auf
Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz
ausgerichtet ist, wirklich
beeindruckend aus. Hier ist ein SVG von
Super Mario, der Kaffee mit Peach
trinkt, generiert durch GPT-4o. Und
dann schau dir an, was Mixtral 8x22B
Flash generiert hat. Ich sage nicht,
dass es zwangsläufig besser ist, aber
für ein Modell, das schnell und
effizient zu sein scheint, ist das ein
wirklich kompetentes Ergebnis. Nun, es
gibt noch viel mehr zu besprechen, also
tauchen wir einfach direkt ein. Aber
Leute, es würde mir wirklich die Welt
bedeuten, wenn ihr diesem Video ein „
Gefällt mir“ geben und den Kanal
abonnieren könntet, da es mir wirklich
hilft, jeden Tag Videos für euch zu
erstellen. Also, ich wäre euch
wirklich sehr dankbar, wenn ihr das tun
könntet. Ihr stoßt auf einen Fehler
in eurer App. Ihr fügt ihn in euren
Agenten ein und er fängt an zu raten,
weil die allgemeine Websuche ihn mit
Blog-Spam-Aggregatoren und einem vier
Jahre alten Stack-Overflow-Thread
füttert. Genau das löst der Firecrawl
Developer Index. 70 Millionen
Primärquellen mit Readmes,
Dokumentationen, Issues und
zusammengeführten Pull Requests, die
täglich aktualisiert werden. Fügt
also einfach den tatsächlichen Fehler
in verständlichem Englisch ein. Ihr
erhaltet das Problem zurück, den Pull
Request, der es behoben hat, und das
Dokument mit der passenden Textpassage
bereits extrahiert. Kein zweites Skript
am DevDay, ihr offener Benchmark von
100 echten Entwickleranfragen. Er
übertraf jeden anderen Index bei der
Trefferquote und bei Issues sowie Pull
Requests, bei denen Breaking Changes
tatsächlich diskutiert werden. Das ist
mehr als doppelt so gut wie die native
Websuche. Mit einer Zeile lässt es
sich in Cloud Code, Cursor, Codeium
oder jeden MCP-Client einbinden. Kein
API-Key zum Start erforderlich. Tausend
kostenlose Credits jeden Monat. Also,
hört auf zu raten.
Firecrawl.dev/developerindex. Und danke
an Firecrawl für das Sponsoring des
heutigen Videos. Fangen wir mit dem
wahrscheinlich größten OpenAI-Leak
für den DevDay an, denn „OpenAI o“
ist offiziell im Code von ChatGPT
aufgetaucht. Den geleakten Referenzen
zufolge ist das kleine „o“
tatsächlich der Produktname von
OpenAIs kommendem „Always-on“-
Assistenten. Er soll 63 Sprachen
unterstützen und die Referenzen deuten
darauf hin, dass mehrere Pro-Stufen
Zugriff darauf erhalten könnten. Ein
weiterer Codename hierfür ist „AON
“. Und OpenAI war dabei auch nicht
gerade subtil, denn OpenAI-Accounts
haben das scheinbare „o“-Logo
gepostet, während Tibbo, einer der
Haupt-Produktleiter bei OpenAI, in den
letzten Tagen auf X über „o“
geteasert hat. Wir haben auch gesehen,
wie „o“ kurzzeitig auf dem
Upgrade-Bildschirm von ChatGPT erschien
, während interne Konfigurationen „o
“ als Anzeigename und „negative o
“ als E-Mail-Suffix referenzieren.
Das könnte darauf hindeuten, dass
dieser Assistent letztendlich in der
Lage sein wird, E-Mails zu bearbeiten
und Aufgaben in eurem Namen zu
erledigen. Aber hier wird es erst
richtig interessant. „o“ soll
angeblich OpenAIs Antwort auf Agenten
wie Operator, MultiOn und Hermes sein,
die speziell für langwierige Aufgaben
entwickelt wurden. Anstatt ihm eine
Aufgabe zu geben und wenige Minuten
später eine Antwort zu erhalten,
könnte man „o“ potenziell etwas
geben, woran es arbeitet, und es
stunden-, tage-oder sogar wochenlang
operieren lassen. Das zugrunde liegende
System wurde Berichten zufolge mit dem
Codenamen „AON“ in Verbindung
gebracht. Wie ich bereits erwähnte,
könnte eine Variante von Astra
verwendet werden, die für diese
langfristigen Aufgaben optimiert ist.
Das lässt mich vermuten, dass es
vielleicht „Minor“ sein könnte,
also „Astra Minor“ als das Modell,
das dahintersteckt. Die Idee ist jedoch
, dass O eine eigene Cloud-Umgebung
erhalten könnte, in der es Dinge
einrichten, Code ausführen,
recherchieren und kontinuierlich
arbeiten kann, bis das Ziel erreicht
ist. Es gibt sogar Gerüchte, dass es
mehrere Agenten einbeziehen könnte,
die kommunizieren und gemeinsam an
derselben Aufgabe arbeiten. Einige
Details sind zwar noch Leaks und
Spekulationen, insbesondere wie genau
AON und Astra in das Endprodukt passen,
aber OpenAI verfügt bereits über
einen Großteil der Infrastruktur für
gehostete Umgebungen, lang laufende
Aufgaben und Agenten-Workflows. Und da
der Dev Day am 29. September bevorsteht
, müssen wir vielleicht nicht mehr
lange warten, um herauszufinden, was O
tatsächlich ist. Eine weitere
potenziell riesige Ankündigung zum Dev
Day ist, dass OpenAI seine
ultraschnelle API für deutlich mehr
Entwickler erweitert, da ein neuer
Geschwindigkeitswähler für die
Response API Playground entdeckt wurde,
der Entwicklern drei Optionen bietet:
Standard, Fast und Ultra-Fast. OpenAI
hat Ultra-Fast nun direkt in seine
API-Dokumentation als
zugangsbeschränkte Service-Stufe
aufgenommen. Ultra-Fast an sich ist
nicht völlig neu, da OpenAI es letzten
Monat offiziell für ausgewählte
Kunden vorgestellt hat, bei denen GPT-
4o bis zu 750 Token pro Sekunde
generieren und bis zu 14-mal schneller
als Standard laufen konnte. Es wird von
Cabris betrieben und der Zugang blieb
bisher extrem begrenzt. Diese neuen
Hinweise deuten jedoch darauf hin, dass
OpenAI sich darauf vorbereiten könnte,
den ultraschnellen Zugang rund um den
Dev Day zu erweitern und diese enorme
Inferenzgeschwindigkeit potenziell
einer viel größeren Gruppe von
Entwicklern zugänglich zu machen. Und
wenn man dies mit dem kürzlich
entdeckten 500-
Dollar-ChatGPT-Pro-Max-Plan kombiniert,
der die schnellsten Antworten
verspricht, scheint hier eine viel
größere Geschichte dahinterzustecken.
Vielleicht erhalten diese Leute Zugriff
auf diesen neuen ultraschnellen Modus.
Ich spekuliere nur, aber das könnte
der Grund sein. Und OpenAI hat massiv
in Infrastruktur und Geschwindigkeit
investiert. Wir könnten also an einen
Punkt gelangen, an dem Entwickler im
Wesentlichen wählen können, wie
wichtig ihnen Latenz ist. Standard für
normale Arbeitslasten, Fast wenn Latenz
eine Rolle spielt und Ultra-Fast, wenn
man Frontier-Modelle benötigt, die
fast sofort antworten. Und da der Dev
Day vor der Tür steht, würde es mich
nicht wundern, wenn die Infrastruktur
eines der größten Themen der
Veranstaltung wird. Wenn Sie die besten
KI-Tools, Workflows und
Veröffentlichungen vor allen anderen
haben möchten, abonnieren Sie meinen
kostenlosen Newsletter über den Link
in der Beschreibung unten, der komplett
kostenlos ist. Ich wollte noch ein paar
andere Dinge erwähnen, und zwar hat
Tibbo im Grunde gesagt, dass er den Dev
Day kaum erwarten kann und er hat
betont, dass dies der beste Dev Day
wird, den wir je hatten. Das setzt
natürlich einen sehr hohen Standard
für diese Entwicklerkonferenz. Eine
weitere Sache ist, dass viele Leute
nach den Resets gefragt haben, und der
Zeitpunkt ist wirklich verrückt, denn
Tibbo hat gesagt, dass nächste Woche
weitere Resets kommen, was bedeutet,
dass wir vielleicht ein neues Modell
bekommen. Vielleicht wird der
Astro-Miner veröffentlicht, um diese
Behauptung zu stützen, aber ich
spekuliere hier nur. Aber die Sache ist
die, dass uns viele Resets bevorstehen,
und das ist einfach wahnsinnig; ich
liebe wirklich, was OpenAI da macht.
Als Nächstes haben wir noch mehr
Informationen über Claude Sonnet 3.5.
Und ich glaube ernsthaft, dass
Anthropic versuchen könnte, dies genau
zum Dev-Day zu veröffentlichen, als
weiteren Seitenhieb gegen OpenAI.
Anthropic hat offiziell bestätigt,
dass Sonnet 3.5 in den nächsten Wochen
kommt, aber Leaks behaupten, dass
Partner bereits Zugriff auf einen
weiteren Checkpoint erhalten haben, der
angeblich noch besser ist als der erste
. Es gibt auch Berichte, dass Sonnet
3.5 mit intensiven Tests in Claude Code
begonnen hat, wobei Tester es als
wahnsinnig schnell und effizient
beschreiben, mit mehr von diesem
natürlichen, menschenähnlichen
Kommunikationsstil, den die Leute an
den vorherigen Sonnet-Modellen liebten.
Diese Testberichte wurden noch nicht
offiziell bestätigt, also genießen
Sie sie mit Vorsicht, aber ich habe
dieses Modell selbst getestet und bin
wirklich begeistert von seinen
Fähigkeiten. Ich habe sogar ein paar
Beispiele in meinem letzten Video
gezeigt. Aber das Wichtigste hier ist
potenziell das
Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis. Die
gemunkelten Preise liegen bei 2 $ pro
Million Input-Token, 10 $ pro Million
Output-Token und 20 Cent pro Million
Cache-Reads. Wichtig ist jedoch, dass
das genau das ist, was das aktuelle
Sonnet 3 kostet. Wir wissen also noch
nicht, ob diese Zahlen tatsächlich zum
3.5 gehören. Und erinnern Sie sich
daran, was gerade mit Opus passiert ist
. Anthropic sagt, Opus 3.5 wurde über
30%schneller und kostet bei typischen
Arbeitslasten 40%weniger als Opus 3.
Wenn Sonnet also auch nur annähernd
den Leistungssprung macht, den wir von
Opus 3 auf 3.5 gesehen haben, während
es die Preise und die Geschwindigkeit
auf Sonnet-Niveau beibehält, könnte
Sonnet 3.5 ein absolutes Monster werden
. Und ich werde sagen, dass dieses
Modell in jeder Hinsicht besser ist als
GPT-4o. Das ist also eine weitere
gewagte Behauptung von mir persönlich,
die auf einigen Tests basiert, die ich
durchgeführt habe. Ich weiß, ihr seid
die Minecraft-Klone leid, aber hier hat
Sonnet 3.5 "High", das wir oben sehen,
diesen unglaublichen Minecraft-Klon mit
Texturen sowie vielen anderen Elementen
generiert, die dem Original oder einem
Klon hinzugefügt wurden, der den
ursprünglichen Sandbox-Klon nachahmt.
Unten haben wir dann Astra, das in der
Lage war, diesen Minecraft-Klon im
High-Thinking-Modus zu erstellen. Und
Sie können sehen, dass Sonic 5.5 viel
besser aussieht, da es offensichtlich
das Shader-Paket sowie sogar eine Karte
oben rechts hinzufügen konnte. Es hat
also ein paar weitere Funktionen
hinzugefügt, die wir bei dem, was das
Astra-Modell ausgeben konnte, nicht
einmal sehen würden. Das zeigt also
allein schon, wie leistungsfähig
dieses Modell in Bezug auf seine
Kreativität sowie seinen Output-Umfang
ist. Als ich dieses Video ursprünglich
aufnahm, war Miniax M 3.1 Flash nur in
einem frühen Commit eines Pull
Requests im GitHub-Repo von Miniax
entdeckt worden. Interessanterweise
wurden diese Verweise tatsächlich
entfernt, bevor der PR zusammengeführt
wurde. Damals sah es also so aus, als
hätten wir ein frühes Leak erwischt,
was wir auch taten. Aber buchstäblich
während ich dieses Video
zusammenstellte, hat Miniax offiziell
die M 3.1 Flash Preview gestartet. Und
jetzt ist es über Miniax Code live,
und Miniax positioniert es als sein
neuestes Textmodell, das speziell für
die tägliche Entwicklung gebaut wurde,
mit Fokus darauf, schnell, zuverlässig
und zu allem fähig zu sein, von
schnellen Bugfixes bis hin zum Aufbau
vollständiger Funktionen. Das
entwickelte sich von einem geleakten
Modell zu einer offiziellen
Veröffentlichung, während ich dieses
Video aufnahm, was irgendwie lustig ist
. Und es fasst auch buchstäblich
zusammen, wie schnell sich der
KI-Bereich gerade bewegt. Wenn Ihnen
dieses Video gefällt und Sie den Kanal
unterstützen möchten, können Sie
eine Spende über die
Super-Thanks-Option unten in Betracht
ziehen. Oder Sie können unserem
privaten Discord beitreten, wo Sie
monatlich Zugriff auf mehrere
Abonnements verschiedener KI-Tools
erhalten, sowie tägliche
KI-Nachrichten, exklusive Inhalte und
vieles mehr. Und bisher bin ich von den
Ergebnissen ziemlich beeindruckt. Dies
ist eine Pakakota, die als Voxel-Art
generiert wurde. Und hier können Sie
die Qualität sehen. Hier wurde
offensichtlich die Atmosphäre
hinzugefügt, sowie viele der Elemente,
die wir bei modernsten Modellen sehen.
Aber die Tatsache, dass diese
Flash-Variante tatsächlich in der Lage
ist, so etwas auszugeben, ist wirklich
beeindruckend. Sie können die
Kirschblüte, den See oder den Teich
und ein paar andere Elemente sehen, die
mit dieser spezifischen Ausgabe
generiert wurden. Also, ich liebe die
Ausgabequalität dieses speziellen
Modells wirklich. Und hier ist eine
weitere Demo und ein Vergleich. Der
Prompt war, eine SVG-Illustration von
Super Mario beim Kaffeetrinken mit
jedem zu erstellen. Und das ist es, was
das GBT6 Pro generiert hatte.
Offensichtlich ist es viel besser. Und
der Detailgrad ist definitiv wahnsinnig
. Aber schauen Sie sich an, was Miniax
M 3.1 Flash generiert hat. Dies ist ein
Modell, das überraschend gut mithalten
kann. Offensichtlich nicht auf
demselben Niveau, aber es erzeugt eine
ziemlich detaillierte und kohärente
Szene, besonders für ein Modell, das
stark auf Geschwindigkeit und Effizienz
ausgelegt ist. Ich sage nicht, dass es
GPT-4o in diesem einen Test direkt
schlägt, aber die Tatsache, dass ein
Flash-Modell so etwas produzieren kann,
ist wirklich wettbewerbsfähig und sehr
beeindruckend. Als Nächstes kommt die
LongChat 2.5 Vorschau, die in den
nächsten zwei Wochen auf OpenRouter
kostenlos sein wird. Hier erhalten Sie
Zugriff auf ein Kontextfenster von
einer Million Token. Sie erhalten
Multimodalität mit diesem Modell und
keinerlei Datenspeicherung. Man macht
also ein echtes Schnäppchen mit diesem
Modell, da es leistungsmäßig ziemlich
konkurrenzfähig ist. Es ist zwar
offensichtlich nicht das Beste beim
Programmieren oder in anderen Bereichen
, um neue Bestmarken zu setzen, aber es
ist in den meisten Kategorien und
Domänen durchaus solide. Sie können
es also wahrscheinlich für die
nächsten zwei Wochen als Ihren
täglichen Begleiter nutzen. Zuletzt
wollte ich mit einem Knall abschließen
. Und hier wollte ich eine Opus 5.5-
Generierung präsentieren. Das ist
etwas, das mich immer wieder aufs Neue
umhaut. Dieses Modell ist einfach so
einzigartig und unglaublich. Hier hat
es einen kompletten Minecraft-Klon von
Grund auf neu aufgebaut, fast
vollständig durch Code. Und der Umfang
dieses Projekts ist lächerlich. Wir
sprechen hier von 100.000 Zeilen
Spielcode, 26.000 Zeilen Testcode,
1.000 automatisierten Tests und 775
Dateien, wobei der Agent bisher etwa 25
Stunden daran gearbeitet hat. Aber noch
verrückter ist, dass es 783 Bilder und
184 Sounds durch Code generiert hat. Es
hat sogar eine komplette Anleitung im
Spiel erstellt. Wenn also jemand
einsteigen möchte, kann er die
Spielmechanik lernen und das Spiel
tatsächlich spielen. Aber das ist
etwas, das in Bezug auf das
Originalspiel tatsächlich ziemlich
genau ist. Das sieht man an der
Befehlszeile sowie natürlich an vielen
dieser anderen Texturen, die generiert
wurden. Genau hier werden Dinge wie
langlebige Coding-Agenten wirklich
interessant. Oder wenn man sich von
kleinen Demos hin zu Modellen bewegt,
die automatisch ein ganzes Spiel
erstellen. Es ist in der Lage, über
ein paar Stunden hinweg massiv zu
arbeiten und ein Projekt mit mehreren
Dateien auszugeben, für das ein
Entwickler mehrere Wochen brauchen
würde–und das alles in nur ein paar
Tagen. Das ist der Wahnsinn, Leute. Das
war's dann auch schon, Leute, mit dem
heutigen Video. Ich werde euch
definitiv auf dem Laufenden halten, was
in der nächsten Woche passiert. Ich
werde auch mein ausführliches Video
zum neuen MiniMax-Modell machen. Also
bleibt unbedingt dran. Aber mit diesem
Gedanken, Leute, hoffe ich, dass euch
das heutige Video gefallen hat und ihr
einen Mehrwert daraus ziehen konntet.
Falls ihr es noch nicht getan habt,
schaut euch den World of AI Insider
Club an. Werft einen Blick auf die
World of AI Vibe Coding-Plattform und
den Benchmark sowie unseren zweiten
Kanal, den Newsletter, den Discord und
folgt mir auf Twitter, um über alles,
was im KI-Bereich passiert, auf dem
Laufenden zu bleiben. Und zu guter
Letzt: Abonniert den Kanal, aktiviert
die Glocke, gebt diesem Video ein Like
und schaut euch unsere früheren Videos
an, damit ihr immer über das
Weltgeschehen im Bereich KI informiert
bleibt. Aber mit diesem Gedanken, Leute
, habt einen großartigen Tag.
Verbreitet Positivität, und wir sehen
uns schon bald wieder. Er leidet.